[Music]
by now we have fallen in love with the
entire cast of descendants - but what if
the iconic roles were played by
different stars stay tuned to see who
dove Cameron could lose her job - are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more now let's talk
about a different cast of descendants -
harry hook who doesn't love to look at
harry hook and descendants - he is just
so beautiful Thomas Doherty plays the
character perfectly but you know who
might also look pretty dreamy as Harry
Cole Sprouse we know he has been killing
it on Riverdale but no one can forget
that he got his start on the Disney
Channel he has those same piercing eyes
that Thomas has so wouldn't be that big
of the junk to switch the characters out
for us wouldn't you just love staring at
Cole for the whole movie we know we
would Disney a let's make it happen
please Gil speaking of hotties let's
talk about Gil for a second though he is
meant to be a villain he is after all
the son of Gaston we can't help but love
to look at him he's pretty happy
go-lucky
which doesn't hurt things either though
we aren't really in the market for any
villains right now we wouldn't mind
spending a little time with Gil right
now he's played by Dylan play fair
Dylan looks great and does a good job in
the role but what if Shawn Mendes
actually landed the role of Gil can you
imagine just take a second and think
about it his musical talents paired with
his good lucks saloon Jane let's switch
gears and talk about the good kids for a
second first up is Jane in the film
Jane is shy and immediately afraid of
the villains this could have been due to
the fact that she couldn't use magic at
the beginning of film she does however
mistrust mal later in the good world
where Jane really needs is a little edge
to her and who better to give her that
edge than Selena Gomez currently Jane is
played by Brenna D amico and while we
love her we really think that Selena
could encompass Jane sweetness while
adding a little flare chad charming up
next is the resident dream king of the
film chat charming and by dream king we
mean he's only the king in his dreams
chad is awful he's the son of Cinderella
and Prince Charming but his personality
needs some work seriously he is so
annoying right now in the film
place I did a diet Goodacre but Jedediah
seems like too much of a goody two-shoes
to really add the underhanded element to
the role that it needs don't you think
that Zac Efron would make an amazing
Chad charming he's got the good looks
down but he can also look really
sinister if he needs to plus we just
love to look at him fairy godmother how
many of you hated when your moms would
show up at school it's really not a good
feeling especially if you're in trouble
it was always a little embarrassing well
Jane's mother fairy godmother is always
at school because she's the headmistress
of auradon prep she even gives remedial
goodness 101 lessons in the movie she is
played by Melanie Paxson but what if we
Alan Baker got the role do you remember
her she was the mother on good luck
charlie
we loved her on that show so why not
watch her in one of our favorite movies
we think she would fit right into the
film uma back to the villain side for a
second you can't talk about villain kids
without bringing up uma uma is the
daughter of ursula and pretty much the
main antagonist in the movie she is the
leader of her own crew of pirates and
believes she's the queen of the Isle of
the Lost
though she may be evil she is not afraid
to go after what she wants and we can
respect that
China and McClain currently plays the
role of uma but what if we switched it
up a bit
what if Skye Jackson played the role we
watched her play Zuri Ross on Jessie and
she does amazing at that the only person
who could bring the sass needed to play
uma other than China is Skye evey can
you imagine being the daughter of the
Evil Queen usually mothers tell you that
looks don't matter but that is not the
case at all with the Evil Queen and Evie
Evie was raised to believe that beauty
was all that mattered which is why she
was kind of excited to go to art on
crack she felt like there she would be
able to find a perfect prince to match
her good looks thankfully she eventually
learned that good looks aren't
everything Evie is portrayed by the
beautiful Sophia Carson but you know who
would also do an amazing job in that
role Camila Mendez
you know from Riverdale she has the
looks that could definitely pull off the
role of Evie Ben we know you didn't
think that we would finish this list
without including Ben did you who could
leave out the next in line for the
thrown then is the son of Belle and the
Beast then is basically what every girl
wants their boyfriend to be he also
stands up for people who are being
treated badly anyway Ben's character is
portrayed by Mitchell hope but you know
who would also do an amazing job in the
role Ross Lynch remember he was Austin
moon in Austin and Ally
wouldn't that be a great way to shake
things up Carlos de Vil next up we have
good ol Carlos de Ville for a villains
kid he is actually pretty kind and
gentle
unfortunately that made him the target
of a good bit of bullying in the film he
actually grew up with a weird fear of
dogs and how he went to our don prep and
met dude the two became best friends
pretty quickly Cameron Boyce plays the
role of Carlos but what if we took
another Disney Channel star and put him
in the role you know Camille McFadden
from KC undercover we think he would fit
in just fine
mal obviously we had to include mal on
this list lady Maleficent Bertha is one
of the main characters in the film she
is the daughter of Maleficent mal is a
natural leader and decides to help her
mother by stealing the fairy godmothers
magic wand but over the course of the
film she falls in love and realizes that
doing evil is not fun for her in the
film mal is portrayed by dove Cameron we
absolutely love dove in the role but it
would have been super interesting if
Bella Thorne had been cast in the role
Bella absolutely doesn't care what
people think and would have made an
amazing mouth don't you agree
that's it for what it could send them to
had a different cast who else would you
have liked to see in the film let us
know in the comments
[Music]